hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime operor and today i will be
considering the possibility that a time
traveling quirk
exists in the boku no hero world and
that this quirk could play a major role
in the future of the story there has
been a ton of speculation within the mha
fandom about potential time travel
ever since all those theories emerged
that bakugou
might have traveled back in time to
become the second one for all
user with the latest crazy developments
in the manga
it is time to re-examine this theory and
the possibility that a game-changing
time travel quirk
will appear in the future if you enjoy
our boku no hero videos and you want to
see more just leave a like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons for making videos like
this one possible i will talk more about
patreon at the end of the video but for
now please be advised that this video
will contain boku no hero manga spoilers
all of the information that we have in
the manga so far is
fair game so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
so after hundreds of chapters of waiting
and wondering
the mha manga finally revealed the
second
and third users of one for all the manga
revealed
their faces and it revealed that the two
of them were part of a resistance
movement against
all for one back at a time when offer
one was at the peak of his
power these two guys were the people who
rescued
the first one for all user from one for
all's captivity
and so we have these guys to thank for
the fact that one for all became
what it is today without them one for
all might have died
with the first user whose name we now
know was
yoichi shigaraki but before this reveal
there was a popular theory within the
fandom that the second one for all user
might have been an older bakugou who
traveled back in time and the reason why
he had to travel back in time was to
make sure that the quirk one for all
is successfully passed from generation
to generation all the way down to deku
this theory was primarily inspired by
the second user's silhouette
which for a long time was the only
visual representation that we had
of the second user the silhouette showed
him as having a similar hairstyle to
bakugo
and the silhouette also appeared to show
him with similar gear to that of
bakugo's hero costume there was also a
side theory that the third one for all
user was actually kirishima
and that both bakuga and kirishima
travel to the past
together the recent face reveals
confirmed that the third user is
definitely not kirishima and while the
second user does have a passing
resemblance to bakugou
it is all but confirmed that it is not
him i know that some people are still
holding out hope that this
might be an older bakugo but to me it
seems clear that he is not
even though this particular theory about
time travel and boku no hero did not
pan out this whole thing made me wonder
does
some type of time traveling or time
manipulation exist
in mha or could it exist in the future
we know that many shonen series include
some sort of
op time manipulation ability including
black clover one piece dragon ball super
jojo's bizarre adventure wakfu and many
more and yes i did just name drop wakfu
because noximilian
is an amazing villain even mha itself
has already introduced
several quirks that are connected to
time or affect
time in some way even though they are
not capable of actual
time travel this includes chronostasis
a quirk that allows its user to slow
down the movements of anything or anyone
that he touches with his hair
sir nighti's quirk which allowed him to
see into someone else's future
and of course aries quirk which allows
her to rewind a person's body
to a previous state this could mean
healing their injuries by rewinding them
to a point in time before they were
injured
or it could mean erasing them out of
existence altogether by rewinding them
to a point in time before they even
existed
so the existence of quirks like these
and
aries quirk in particular have sparked a
ton of speculation about
actual time travel occurring in mha at
some point
in the future rewind especially seems to
have been a key component of the bakugou
is the second one for all user theory
namely many of those who believed in
that theory argued that it could have
been achieved through the awakening
of aerys quirk clearly arie is slowly
learning to control her overpowered
quirk
and recently in the manga she was even
able to restore meteosquirk
so maybe in the future aries quirk will
awaken
and she will be able to not only rewind
people's bodies to a previous state
but also rewind time itself or send
other people into the past i know that
many people will now reject
all aspects of the bakugou time travel
theory because the second and third user
did not
turn out to be bakugo and kirishima but
i do think that one part of the theory
the part about the potential awakening
of aries quirk is
absolutely plausible we've seen that
quirk awakenings in one form or another
can become
absolute game changers as was the case
with getting
toga shigaraki and twice and since
eddie's quirk was already hyped up
as incredibly overpowered imagine what
she could do once she learns to control
it
and once it hypothetically awakens this
is when time travel or some sort of
heavy duty time manipulation
could come into play the other key
factor to remember
is the existence of the quirk enhancing
drug trigger
if someone with a quirk like ares
artificially enhances that quirk using
trigger
it could potentially unlock some time
traveling type ability
and finally we cannot overlook the
importance of quirk singularity
quirk singularity is a concept that dr
ujiko claims to come up with first
many years ago it refers to the idea
that as new generations of quirk users
are born
the quirks that the children are born
with will become stronger and stronger
as
different powerful quirks mix together
to create
even more op quirks the world will
eventually get to the point where the
quirk that a user manifests
becomes too strong for him or her to
control
as ujjiko puts it the memory will exceed
the hardware meaning that the power of
the quirk will exceed the capabilities
of the quark user's body according to
ujico
this has already been happening since
the fourth generation of quirk users
arie herself can be considered a prime
example
of quirk singularity at work the quirk
that she manifested as a child was a
mutation that didn't resemble the quirks
of either of her parents
and it was so powerful that she couldn't
control it
as we know her own father died as a
result of aries
inability to control her quirk fujiko
believes that as
more quirks continue to mix together
over the coming generations
this phenomenon will become more common
and eventually the entire society will
be thrown
into chaos well it's pretty much in
chaos already but the point is
if arie isn't the one to unlock some
sort of time travel ability
then a new quirk could emerge in the
future that unlocks
just such an ability because of quirk
singularity
new generations of quirk users will
start developing stronger and stronger
quirks
so it is possible that one of these
quirks will have the ability to
manipulate
time itself if you ask me whether a time
travel quirk or some other type of
overpowered time manipulation quirk is
possible in mha
i would say yes absolutely if aries
quirk awakens it
could potentially send people back in
time instead of just rewinding their
bodies to a previous state
and if aerys quirk doesn't allow for
time travel
then some other quirk could
theoretically make that happen
it could be an existing time-related
quirk that develops time travel
abilities
after it is artificially enhanced or
after it awakens
or it could be a quirk that is yet to
emerge sometime in the future
as a result of the quirk singularity
phenomenon
aries own quirk has already proven that
quirk singularity is very much
real and something similar could happen
again
this time with actual time travel a time
travel quirk that is too powerful to
control
could activate on its own maybe leading
to someone
accidentally being sent back in time or
forward in time
that one event could permanently change
the entire world of boku no hero
and become an entire new ark all on its
own
or it could be used as the plot for a
future non-canon movie that ends up
making a ton of money but doesn't affect
the main timeline so yes i do think that
a time traveling quirk or a quirk that
can manipulate time in some other
overpowered way
may already exist in mha and even if it
doesn't it
may appear in the future aries quirk
could evolve
into a time traveling quirk when it
awakens or an entirely new quirk could
appear
and develop such abilities but will this
actually happen in the story even if it
is technically
possible i honestly don't know because
whenever you introduce
time travel things can get complicated
quickly and of course
such an overpowered quirk could
potentially throw the entire power
scaling situation in boku no hero
completely out of whack
that is why using time travel in a
self-contained
semi-canon movie may be the best way to
go about it
whatever happens though time travel is
always an interesting concept
to think about and i personally love
stories that are able to handle time
travel
in an effective way but let me know what
you guys think do you agree with me that
time traveling or time manipulation
quirks are
possible in mha and if so
do you think that we will ever actually
see a quirk that allows its user to send
himself or someone else
through time could that happen with
aries quirk once it awakens
or would it be another quirk altogether
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more pocono hero content right
here on the channel
please leave that like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all i know it's annoying but it's the
only way to make sure that youtube will
actually
show you our videos you can also hit me
up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
alpha sigma red haired raven and av
these guys are absolute mad lads and
disciples of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chi bang
emperor otaku spidey life canal tungsten
targus
baked buddhist and you know finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki
cricket xp
rathundera very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joy and
garcia
ted no ted isparky65 jessica lafond
metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you